next a young couple that have found the
secret of marital happiness they share
everything including her wardrobe gently
and Tony Curtis
Janet who was that lady I saw you with
well that was no lady that was my
husband they didn't see the picture we
may all be arrested a while ago Richard
Conte said the art director is to the
movie what the cake is to the frosting
well there could be no cake and no
frosting if someone didn't create the
recipe and that someone is the
screenwriter the play is still the thing
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material from another medium
are Wendell Mayes anatomy of a murder
Carlton Berg Ben Hur Robert Anderson the
nun story Neil Patterson room at the top
Billy Wilder and I al diamond for some
like it hot
the winner is room at the top Neil
Patterson
this is mr. Jack Clayton
the table for mr. Neal Patterson
mr. Clayton will accept the award for
mr. Patterson on behalf of Neil I can
only say to all of you thank you very
much indeed the best story and
screenplay written directly for the
screen the nominees are
francois truffaut and marcel musi for
the 400 blows Ernest Lehman for North by
Northwest
story by Paul King and Joseph stone and
screenplay by Stanley Shapiro and
Maurice Richmond for operation petticoat
story by Russell rouse and Clarence
green and screenplay by Stanley Shapiro
and Maurice whistling for pillow talk
Ingmar Bergman for wild strawberries and
the winner is story by Russell brows and
Clarence wing screenplay by Stanley
Shapiro and Maurice Richland pillow talk
you dream about this but when you get up
here you still don't believe it's a
wonderful honor thank you thank you very
much
we have a note from mr. Stanley Shapiro
I am trapped downstairs in the
gentlemen's lounge it seems I have
rented a faulty tuxedo I would like to
thank you all upstairs for the high
honor you paid me